[Music]
tamara mowry just
full on rocked out to doja cat's song
bearing her name
and it's everything you never knew you
totally needed
on thursday the 42 year old actress
shared a clip
dancing in the car to doji cat's track
titled
yes tia tamara
the rapper dropped the track back in
2019 with rico nasty
and in the 90s inspired music video the
two dress up like tamara
and her twin tia from their sister
sister days
denim jackets and bucket hats on point
and tamara she clearly loves it the
actress captioned the clip on instagram
quote
car karaoke to tia tamara by doja cat
i am obviously a big fan of this song
it's great to see tamara smiling and
looking so
happy she recently had an emotional
homecoming to her husband adam housley
and their two kids at home in napa
california
after being away for work
tamara shared that clip on instagram
writing in part
quote so grateful to have a husband and
family that supports mommy's dreams
my children are eight and five now and
they are pretty much aware
when mommy's not there and they needed
their mama
and she finally reunited with her twin
sister tia
after a year apart due to the pandemic i
know for a fact when we see each other
we're just we're just gonna we're gonna
cry that was tamara back in october
revealing to et that she hadn't seen her
twin in
months i still haven't seen her
physically because i live in napa
and then um there was a surge in la
uh right when we were we were actually
gonna head up there there was a surge in
la
and it wasn't wise for all of us you
know to
to kind of go there we were gonna meet
up she's working on family reunion and
the time
it didn't work and in march tia revealed
to et
that they finally had their big reunion
yes i have
i was able to see my sister was it
yes of course we were so happy to see
each other
and we hadn't seen each other in so long
now we can
only hope for a tia and tamara duet of
doja cat's tia tamara
[Music]
my twins big like tiara